I love how complex it is on the inside
but when you look at it from a distance
it's so simple and pure and elegant that
you would never suspect that it's such
an architectural masterpiece like it
follows all of the forms of a fugue
today a prelude any type of the dance
but when you just listen to it it's just
a charming piece by itself and you don't
have to hear like oh this is an
allemande oh this is a Sarabande
but of course it helps to know so fugue
is when there's two three four five
voices or more if you'd like and each
voice is basically just a line and each
line has a subject but the subjects are
all the same in each line so say the
first voice will enter with the subject
and when the subject is finished then
the second voice enters and does the
subject but usually in a different key
then the third voice enter is when the
second voice is finished with its
subject then the fourth voice enter is
when the third is done and so on and so
forth all in the 48 total preludes and
fugues in the well-tempered clavier and
since i've learned 20 that means I have
28 more to go not bad
in box music there's always a lot of
lines going and if you have say a to
voice view each line is completely
independent from each other which is
really confusing to play of course
because you have to pay attention to one
like one character and then the other
one has to be completely different
character but when you move on to the
bigger fugues with three four or five
voices that's a really really hard task
to do because you only have two hands
but you have to take care of basically
five different people playing five
different lines and then on top of that
these five different people are
interacting with each other in ways that
are sometimes a bit surprising like
sometimes they like to say argue with
each other they the voices interrupt
each other and other times they kind of
play with each other and it's a very
friendly piece but there's an outline in
which they all work so say there's a
friendly part and they all work together
but then after that they suddenly turn
against each other so now they're angry
at each other so you have to create the
distinction between those two characters
as well as the five different characters
as well as the interaction between those
five characters and the list goes on and
on of course
I'd have to say my favorite is the art
of fugue because this really showcases
box magnificent few writing I mean it's
the entire sixteen fugues are based on
just one simple subject in the first
fugue that comes in four different
voices but then it's kind of like a set
of variations you have 15 more fields
with each subject as a variation of a
first subject and that works really well
because each one has a different subject
and each subject is unique in its own
way in the fugue itself and oftentimes
in each different fugue
he takes subjects from different fields
and puts them in so I think there's some
fuchs that's you have three different
subjects at the same time and others you
have two different subjects at the same
time so now you're not dealing with just
a few you're dealing with a double fugue
or a triple fuse
so the subject is basically like a very
specific motifs in a piece you have say
a line like da da da da da and that is
mirrored by da da da da da in the second
voice but then the third voice comes in
doing da da da da da and then the first
voice comes in doing da da da
so it's always the same the fugue is the
subject is always set and the sub the
sequence of the notes is always the same
but often Bach will take little bits of
that subject cut it up and place it
random places in the few or he'll take
the subject and transform it to
completely different keys or take it
from major to minor and put it all over
again
okay so when I was really young I loved
playing video games and I kind of
noticed that when you play video games
you have to be really really focused so
if you're playing maybe Mario Kart on
the Nintendo 64 so you're driving along
and of course there's a Koopa waiting to
hit you but if you blink or you say oh I
need to get something to eat or I need
some chips so you put your controller
down and when the Koopa smashes into you
so you die you lose life and of course
you get you in videogames you have
plenty of lives so it's okay
but in box when you're performing you
don't have that kind of a privilege so
you have to stay really focused through
the whole thing and you can't stop
I think that was when I was five or six
I think six I went to this piano
competition in Auckland and my friend
was playing a piano concerto with my
older piano teacher and I think that was
the first time I ever played in a public
which is kind of interesting because it
wasn't actually a performance it was a
competition
I mean of course I get nervous so I just
try to focus on the music itself I try
not to think about anything besides the
music so usually before I walk on stage
I'm just kind of playing the piece over
to myself again and again and walking
through some of the spots where I know I
need to be focused on what kind of a
sound or the character I'm producing
often in Bach if you make a big mistake
it's really difficult to find your way
back so it's almost necessary to just
stop and start over again which I've
done that quite a few times but if just
a little mistakes like if you miss a
couple of notes I try to forget about
that section and skip to maybe a few
bars forward so that a few bars forward
I know that I can keep playing and it'll
be fine